hey guys what's up this is andrew for
transtensions.com
so i'm here guys to make a big update on
amcgm of course but on triple q bitcoin
tesla
guys i have
big things to tell you today
they're not really good
we always have a bullish case but i
really want to show you guys what i
think is happening
and what it can create um in terms of
bearish price action on a lot of
assets so let's get into it
oh right guys so
um
let's first
as i know you guys are here for this
quickly have a look at the daily uh
price action on amc
and
so in the last video i was telling you
that we are having a trend line here as
you can see guys the the reactions are
not clean
this is not a good a good sign you know
whenever um you don't have good
reactions and the press action is noisy
it's suggesting that we are in a
corrective move here you can see the
trendline has been naturally respected
we are just above it so i could of
course readjust it
but
you see there's always a way to make it
fit
um
it's not fitting too bad actually
so this could be what is happening
but i'm afraid guys that this is only a
consolidation here and that we are going
to break this on the um
on the downside all right so once again
we can quickly have a look at the usual
indicators volume decreasing on the way
down rather positive
rsi just below the 50 area
rather bearish
um
and we are consolidating close to
support area which is again
the sign that bears are building energy
uh so to me we have two reasons
to think that we might go lower one
reason to think that we might go higher
so let's see we always have
uh a bullish and a bearish case but in
this uh situation i'm afraid we are
going good we we're gonna go to nine um
maybe this week next week
uh and then probably rebound and then
after the rebound this is the question
um
i want to raise guys what is going to
happen in the next three months because
i think that in the next two months we
still gonna have uh bears in control
the situation is too bad for bulls to
really take back control but i'm gonna
come to that guys
uh
i wanna do mcgme first so amc i'm done
support nine resistance
um
13 the
major support is right now this trend
line around
11.7 if we break this on the downside
we'll probably go lower if we manage to
hold above that
uh and
come close to the uh resistance area
around 13 14 maybe we are out of trouble
and we gonna revisit the 20 area sooner
so those are the two cases jamie as
usual jme is holding uh very well guys
so i was telling you that we have this
one two three four five uh bam bam bam i
think this the fifth wave was just a bit
shorter than expected we went to 155
instead of 160 sorry for those who had a
selling order at 160
and that didn't get executed
but guys
uh for sure in the
you know long run we will have higher
levels than this but for now i think we
are correcting i think we can come uh
i'm on a weekly time frame let's go to
daily
uh so what do we have here all right
very clearly the 20-day moving average
is acting as support here you can see
that right away all right we had a nice
bullish reaction
uh here you can see again guys jme rsi
above the 50 area finding support here
so jimmy
strong again above the 20-day moving
average when amc is rather below that
with an rsi i'm on the daily time frame
as well guys so you can see the
difference between amazing jme is
definitely more bullish than amc in the
past two three months guys and it's uh
it can be seen again today um
i'm actually afraid guys that we open
lower on fr on on monday because the
bitcoin has broken 20k i'm gonna come to
that guys i'm after jimmy i'm gonna do
bitcoin but everything is related so
that's why i'm showing you a little bit
what is on bitcoin that's why i believe
we're gonna open lower
uh
yeah it's possible that we hold above
270 yeah there is we're gonna probably
open lower so maybe there's gonna be a
buying opportunity at the 20-day moving
average or 125 stop-loss just below bam
here
this is a trade that could make sense
um
and in this situation we'll probably
find support again here but once again
you can see we have this consolidation
here
on the 20-day moving average tested
every day for the past in the past week
so if we break this we will probably
have some downside to come
um
yes i'm a bit bearish guys you can feel
it i'm a bit bearish guys because the
situation is not nice at all in terms of
macroeconomics in terms of
um
you know global situation with the war
coveyed
i don't see uh a way out of this
in the very uh um
recent future i mean in the very next
future uh in the next few weeks a few
months if you prefer
um
so yeah to uh sum up the situation
resistance at 135 next one around 160
and support 20 day moving average 125 if
we break this we probably go lower uh
yeah lower towards i would say the 100
level and if we able to close above 135
we will have one more shot at going to
the 160 level where we would very likely
be rejected guys so if we are able to go
here i know you guys don't like to sell
but
you know covered calls is a way to
reduce the loss if we go lower
uh you can buy the put options there are
different ways to keep your shares and
not lose money
um
so this is the kind of things that can
be done if we come to uh close to 160
level
uh bam bam bam now bitcoin then i do
triple q so the reason why i'm bearish
guys for the coming week is that bitcoin
is not looking great at all all right
here we had a breakout i personally sold
my bitcoin position here on the retest
around 28
500 something like that
i
then we dropped here this was
expected 30k was a very strong support
as you can see guys it has been tested
multiple times one two three four five
six seven eight nine
20
maybe 20 times and here we consolidated
for a month so that's why i'm telling
you guys when you see a consideration
close to support be careful it's usually
the sign of uh an incoming breakout and
here this is what we had breakout
increase in volume we went lower we
reached the 20k level up personally both
here at 20k my plan was to have a
buddhist reaction
uh towards the
23-25 area
unfortunately we went only to 22
900 uh so i couldn't exit any of my
position that i built here
i'm going to now try to exit
on the retest of the 20k area around
19500 exits maybe 50 75 of my long
position i built at 20k why because i
think we go to 15k guys we have here in
this area a lot of stop losses we're in
a situation that is really looking bad
to me guys because you know that um all
the default company you know that's
taking um
those who offer some very attractive
staking rates
uh they are leveraged guys they are
leveraged and if and they usually pay
the
the interest to the holders using the
money that they get from the new
investors you know this kind of ponzi
scheme a lot of them are built using
this for sure they will never say it but
that's a fact
and um
we might see this coming soon if below
20k those companies that hold billions
of dollars
uh equivalent of bitcoin
um
that they will not be able to hide the
truth
for long so what's going to happen is
that a lot of investors will exit
together
and this would create a liquidity crunch
so those companies
might um
go bankrupt
which will send very bad signals to all
this market because these companies are
not only invested in the
uh crypto market they invested in
everything guys if those companies go
bankrupt it's you know
it's what looks to me like
a very good reason for
a market crash to happen so i'm afraid
if bitcoin stays below 20k i waited
today to make this video because
yesterday we had to breakout it is
confirming today
we are still below 20k
let me zoom in a little bit we have one
day you can see here how how weak is
this market 20k was a very strong
support guys i mean
it was the recent high before this uh
breakout in november december 20
um
and it has only hold for five days one
two three four and fifth day it has
broken so it means that there is no more
buyers only sellers that's really bad
no more buyers on the bitcoin because
everybody bought at 30k guys and
everybody got destroyed so this is the
situation where you know we don't have
any more buyers we have overleveraged
companies that are going to find
themselves
uh in big troubles if bitcoin stays
below 20k now 20 has been broken it
became resistance i'm personally going
to sell this level
um i think i'm not going to be the only
one so
uh i think we are doomed to stay in the
15
20k area
maybe locally go to 10k you know
something like this right
uh
so that's why i want to exit here to be
able to buy 15k and even maybe put some
orders here we will not stay i think
below 15k for more than a few days but
it's possible we go there quickly
um
and i believe that once here everybody
would be liquidated
uh we're gonna we're gonna find buyers
all right here they are buyers for sure
okay
uh
here they are buyers
i believe
but i thought they were buyers at 20k i
was wrong as you can see i mean buyers
didn't fight well so i think that buy is
here but maybe
everybody lost so much money that no one
can buy anymore i don't know
i will personally try to sell here in
order to be
a buyer here because of course i still
believe in the long term um
um
price action on bitcoin i mean i think
that bitcoin cryptocurrencies will be
here for long but i also believe we
entered a crypto winter a crypto winter
um that might last between three more
months and
two more years all right i know it's
there is a big difference but of course
i don't know what's gonna happen i can
only tell you guys that i think we're
gonna reach the bottom around
july august something like this
um
and that then
so this is gonna be the end of the sea
wave maybe at 15 km maybe at 10 km and
then we probably gonna have a strong
bounce
all right
massive maybe go to 20k all right so
here there's gonna be
money to make
we can you know triple the investment if
you buy a 10k i'm not saying we're going
to go to 10k but
15k you know you can double the
investment and here the question is
what's going to happen once this happens
all right around december 22
i'm pretty
you know this scenario makes a lot of
sense to me i'm very
you know confident that something like
this might happen i'm not sure about the
levels but in terms of
um
you know time timing and
price action structure i think we're
going there and the question is what is
going to happen here
um
so it's going to depend on what the
central banks do are they able to ease
um
the measures of you know
lower the rates inject some liquidity
because we will need this
or not if they are maybe we're gonna
have a bull market but if they're not
we're gonna drop again guys all right
we're gonna drop again for the next six
months maybe and then we can even go i
don't even want to imagine that but this
is a very very very bearish case for now
let's not focus on what's going to
happen in gen 23. let's focus on what's
going to happen this summer this summer
we're going to be bearish i believe
until august and then sure there's going
to be some money to make like i said and
it's true for the equity market it's
true for the crypto market
so the idea is to arrive in august with
some money right you need to survive
there
so
you know it's not easy these days i
personally lost some money the past two
weeks
but i made a lot of money just before so
i'm still positive this year and you
know i'm trying to build up on on that
and
now i'm i reduced most of my long
positions on the equity market i'm still
in this long position on bitcoin but i'm
gonna try to exit soon
and the idea is to here reload massively
alright so once again between 16 and 10k
something like that
so that you can catch up this strong
move up all right now let me go back to
triple q
so i just made
the crypto um
price action analysis
now this is the reason why i believe
we're going to open with the gap down on
monday the bitcoin has broken 20k it's
really an important level
it's going to create some um you know
panic probably on the equity market um
so if you look at the weekly time frame
you can you know really see what is
happening guys okay
so
we had look at this strong you know
bubble
that's what it's called right it's a
bubble guys we were in a bubble we knew
that
i personally hoped the bubble could last
a little bit longer but since this
breakout happened
um you know and the fed has tightened uh
their policy
um
there is no more free money in the
market to invest
uh the bible has burst all right let's
be very clear about that um
so right now what is the situation
we have two cases okay so i showed you a
little bit the long term so that you
understand where my support come from
150 is the law of decay 18
um 195 is the high
of july 19
2 35 is the high before kovid
and here 270 is the low in the middle of
the move up after the covet crisis so
right now i'm gonna start a weekly
timeframe and let's analyze i just
showed you my analysis on bitcoin and
the equity market is very tied i mean
uh to what is happening on bitcoin
because bitcoin was in a bubble mode the
equity market as well so we're gonna
find some uh positive correlation
uh when we look at big cycles between
those two markets i believe this i might
be wrong but this is what i believe so
after making my analysis on bitcoin it's
gonna help me to make my analysis on
nasdaq if i forget what i did on bitcoin
i could say that oh look we arrived on
the
weekly 200 week moving average 270 was a
level that i told you guys about already
quite long ago
so we could say all right yeah we might
have uh the the abc could be complete
okay here this abc could be complete
okay forget about that
and we might uh one two three four five
abc one two three four five and we might
see a move up starting here
yes fair enough that's possible that's
very possible
uh
but
given the situation
on the equity on the crypto market given
the situation in the world
inflation kovid that is still not done
with the china having their zero coveted
policy that is just
you know creating lockdowns forever i
think it's good that's gonna stop in the
next six months
uh but
you know when you look at all of that
and you think about how a crisis is
usually starting so i mean we knew that
we're gonna have here six months
correction i announced 280 back in
december you can check in my discord um
of course i'm sometimes announcing
things
um
that don't happen as well i'm not saying
um uh you know i can foresee what's
gonna happen i'm just saying that this
was kind of expected all right and it
happened uh and i was hoping we have a
bounce here but right now
um
i can see we are really not out of
troubles in terms of once again the
situation so
um
and given what is happening on the
uh crypto market and this liquidity
liquidations that could happen and
create a domino effect we know that the
equity market uh has a lot of leverage
as well
and that
you know if we start to really dive
and go to lower levels there's going to
be some selling mechanisms that are
going to start to take place
and that can create really strong moves
down so
my view
uh i hope that the bullish case will
happen but i'm prepared for this
and i think that we might just complete
a one two three that we are in the
middle of a third wave
that is not an abc this was the bullish
case
that we might go to 214
bounce to 270 and then finish this first
move maybe at 230 i don't know maybe 200
you know it's hard to know if it's going
to be like that it's possible as well
i'm just here talking i'm showing you
levels and i'm showing you the structure
then i can't be sure of course which
level is going to be hit during the
structure but something like that
to me it makes more sense that we go to
200 you know even to 200 guys it's
pretty bad i know but this is
you know something that could happen
and then we probably so this is going
together with the viewer have on bitcoin
that we are
we have maybe one more or two more month
of uh bearish uh market
and then we're gonna have a relief all
right so same thing the idea is to load
between 240 and 200
right
you can load that 270 a little bit as
well just in case we go up i personally
uh not gonna do that i'm gonna wait
and load probably here and here and to
catch up this nice move up that's for
sure we're gonna have during the end of
the year i don't know if it's gonna
start in two weeks or in three months
i think in two months i think that's the
lowest level will be
uh mid august something like that right
something like this you see
yeah maybe early september and that's
september
october november december gonna be
bullish all right and that's
uh that this is gonna be at least a b
wave with a nice bull market so let's be
prepared for this first
and then once again same as for bitcoin
guys remember that during bear markets
this is when we see the strongest rally
with a lot of volume with nice moves uh
they really look like uh rallies like
you know
impulsive move up
but there are very tricky b waves so
we're gonna need to be very careful here
so we have time it's gonna be in deck 22
or gen 23
uh because here the market could
collapse again and this could be really
really really what is going to hurt the
economy and this could be an entire
correction of
uh
the move that started guys you know
in 208 even before all right i don't
have enough market data here
but this could be look at this chart
guys if i just
okay
so i think we are correct in this entire
move guys okay
and that this correction might be you
know just like that okay that's possible
i mean the macroeconomics are really bad
guys okay so we need to be prepared for
that
um and and hope it's not gonna happen
but we need to be prepared for that so
this is my view guys quite bearish come
back to gme
um
and i want to talk quickly about tesla
as well tesla is uh okay is the company
where we have
when everything started all right the
meme movement it started with tesla guys
all right this was the first company
that started to trade at very high
levels based on the confidence investors
had in the company in elon musk
so
we could say that if tesla collapses it
would probably drive a lot of meme
stocks lower as well
and tesla is to me not looking so good
and i can quickly give you my levels i
think that 550
is gonna be hit
uh
soon and that we might even go to 300
all right 350
is a possible scenario right and if this
happens if tesla loses 50 of its value
it has now roughly which is possible
guys
then we would probably see breakouts
happening here i'm not trying to create
fad guys i'm i'm just trying to show you
um
what
could happen and i believe personally
that this bearish scenario is very
possible and if this happens
uh
a lot of stocks that are still holding
well would probably see their um levels
breaking so gme for example monitor the
100 level this level is going to be
important guys all right you're not
maybe watching all of my videos but this
remember that because you can use it for
very long time all right logarithmic
scale you just connect the lows and you
have a trend line here if this trendline
breaks guys
i can assure you
that it's gonna be ugly and that it's
gonna be the signal that everything is
collapsing so just you know keep that in
mind
not trying to create fed once again just
sharing my view as honestly as i can
um and so yeah tesla we have so i
i wouldn't go short here it's too late
uh but i believe we're gonna go to 550
minimum and then if we have a bounce
here maybe taking a short position
around 700 would make sense to play the
move here lower once again this would go
together with bitcoin together with
triple q
so
once again i sum up my view i think
we're gonna be bearish for the next one
month to two months
then have a strong rally that could be a
trap so we're gonna be very careful to
see if the situation has really changed
or not if we have good news we have good
news and maybe we are out of trouble but
if we're not and if it's just a
technical rebound uh remember guys that
rallies
happen a lot during bear market so we
will monitor that when it's going to
come so that's it for today i hope you
guys enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button yeah and i forgot
to tell you guys
uh we are meeting today crypto bulls are
meeting today so for those who are
interested just join the discord.com i
hope you are waitlisted
and yeah i just wanted to remind you
that very quickly but i'm sure that
those who are interested already there
so now i can conclude thank you very
much for listening guys and i'm talking
to you very soon so stay close to show
cheers